in this video I want to talk about the
pentose phosphate pathway the purpose of
the pentose phosphate pathway is
essentially to produce different things
and those two different things are NADPH
and RHIB ulos 5 phosphate rib bellows
sounds a lot like ribose and reveal o's
5 phosphate is actually used to make
nucleic acids write in nucleic acids
usually involve the the deoxyribose or
ribose so this 5 card that the pentose
sugar is necessary to make nucleic acids
so this is involved in nucleic acid
synthesis what is NADPH involved in well
NADPH actually provides reducing power
for biosynthesis or biosynthetic
pathways now I just said reducing power
so that means reduction if you recall
from our Co was the way I told you to
remember that an anabolic reaction is a
reductive pathway or anabolic pathways
or reductive processes when and
catabolic processes are oxidative
pathways right so in this case
biosynthesis is essentially an ab ilysm
right building things we're building
biomolecules we're going to need to
reduce things right so NADPH is the
reduced form of nadp+ so that reducing
power is necessary in biosynthesis okay
now the pentose phosphate phosphate
pathway is divided into two phases then
non oxidative and oxidative phases the
non oxidative phase I'm not gonna really
go into too much detail about it's
basically just a series of carbons
shuffling reactions basically if there's
a bunch of different monosaccharide
phosphates and they can either be
anywhere from 3 carbons long to 7
carbons long and they can just shuffle
in between those those three four five
six seven carbons long but the point is
there's
the reactions are reversible but the
point of it essentially the point of the
Ahtna non sedated phase is it allows for
the production of ruby lows 5 phosphate
or i5p
ok when we don't need any D pH so the
pathway can create both of these but if
we only want to create Regulus 5
phosphate then we want to go through the
non oxidative phase however if you want
to create both of these different things
here then we're going to have the
oxidative base take over the oxidative
phase is two steps so we're starting off
with a glucose 6-phosphate or a g6p
which if you recall is a six carbon
molecule and via two steps we're going
to create rib EULA's five phosphate
which of course is five carbons long
okay
again ribose is a five carbon sugar
ruble Oh sounds very similar and the
part of the reason is of course because
it has five carbons so we lost a carbon
here right going from g6p to our 5p how
did we lose it we lost it as a carbon
dioxide now reactions that result in the
production of carbon dioxide they are
irreversible and why is that because
carbon dioxide is a gas if you ever ran
a reaction and if you were in for
instance like an O chem lab or a general
chemistry laboratory and you held the
reaction in a fume hood for example that
reaction if a reaction expelled gas
could you take that gas and just put it
right back into that container whether
it was like a beaker or a flask not
really right once that gas is out it's
out and that's that's pretty much it
normally reactions that reverse or to me
that create gases are irreversible
reactions so and this is why here so
when in these two steps we actually take
each step we take in nadp+
and turn it into an NADPH so in those
two steps we actually create two NADPH
is for every one glucose 6-phosphate
that we have so how does that actually
work well if we start off with a glucose
6-phosphate I've drawn it in its chain
form here via if we add the enzyme
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase or
g6pd h what we'll do is we'll actually
make our first NADPH right from nadp+
so what actually
machine here and here here we went from
an aldehyde to a carboxyl group so we
lost the hydrogen and we created another
bond to oxygen which so g6p was oxidized
and the p+ was reduced so now we have
this reduced form of an AEDPA of we have
NADPH which as for reducing power now
once we have this new molecule here this
six phospho gluconate that if we add six
phosphate group in eight dehydrogenase
which is just the dehydrogenase enzyme
that acts on this we're going to create
that next nad pH right so that's our
second V pH so we created and what we're
going to do is we're going to take
notice here we have we started off with
the six carbon molecule this is still a
six carbon molecule but the reason I've
actually drawn two arrows here is
because there's actually an intermediate
here that I didn't draw it's not really
to necessary to draw what the point is
that we go from this six carbon molecule
to this Ribble is 5 phosphate wire which
is our goal which is a 5 carbon molecule
so what happened here well we lost this
carbon this carboxyl group here as a
carbon dioxide in addition this H group
is now a carbonyl so it was oxidized so
if this thing was oxidized that
something must have been reduced the
nadp+ was reduced to NADPH okay so
that's that for those two those two
phases now when would the pentose
phosphate a pentose phosphate pathway
actually occur and how is it controlled
really really simple actually the
control of the pentose phosphate pathway
all used to know really all you have to
understand is essentially that it uses
g6p right so if there's a if there's g6p
around the pentose phosphate pathway can
happen but it will happen depending on
the needs so g6p is also involving
glycolysis so there's a bunch of g6p
around glycolysis can happen too so it
really is need-based so because g6p can
go onto glycolysis or the pentose
phosphate pathway we think about well
what do we need if we need energy if we
need ATP then we will have g6p go to the
pathway
creates a GP which in this case is by
Collis but if we need NADPH because we
plan on having some biosynthetic
pathways go through then the g6p will go
through the pentose phosphate pathway
simple as that that's about it for the
pentose phosphate pathway I hope that
was helpful thank you for watching